[Music]
so
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock here in the uk you are very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news this morning don't be a
muppet boris johnson tells the un
humanity needs to grow up on climate
change as he quotes a green childhood
hero for many who came at the frog to
drive the message home glass of business
minister paul scully about that and the
energy crisis plus we'll do some
proofreading with labour's steve reed as
his leader pension 14 000 word essay
with his vision for britain also ahead
for you
having kept the nation fit during
lockdown joe wicks now wants to get
pre-school kids into shape he'll join us
a little bit later on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
an all-star lineup will be performing at
a charity concert to mark what would
have been the 81st birthday of john
lennon host bob harris will be talking
us through the lineup later on in the
programme it's thursday the 23rd of
september
we are doing irreversible damage boris
johnson tells world leaders at the
united nations that they must act to
stop climate change
taking responsibility
for the destruction we are inflicting
not just upon our planet
but
upon ourselves
it's time for humanity
to grow up
the prime ministers told world leaders
of the urgent need for a limit on
greenhouse gas emissions but will they
listen
gas on tap the government says co2
production is resuming but there are
still concerns about food shortages on
supermarket shelves we'll hear from the
boss of iceland
looking for a deal the foreign secretary
heads to mexico as britain discusses new
ways of striking a trade agreement with
the united states
a high court judgment is expected which
could prevent unborn babies with
disabilities like downes from being
aborted after 24 weeks
i'm live in la palma where residents
have been warned that sunday's eruption
could bring further acid rain and
earthquakes all because of this a
volcano which is continuing to spew
molten liver lava into the night sky
weather at home largely warm and fine
for central and eastern parts
[Music]
good morning grow up and face the
challenges of climate change the message
from boris johnson to the united nations
he told world leaders they must come to
november's cop 26 summit in glasgow
willing to reach agreement on lowering
carbon emissions and warned that parts
of the world are now uninhabitable there
was even a mention of kermit the frog
from new york our political editor beth
rigby reports
the world's nations gathered in one
place be they friends or foes they all
face one common threat climate change
and amongst all of them it is this
leader who's been charged with making
november's global climate summit really
count
the glasgow cop 26 summit is the turning
point for humanity we must limit the
rise in temperatures whose appalling
effects were visible even this summer to
1.5 degrees we we must come together in
a collective coming of age
we must show
that we have the maturity
and wisdom
to act
and we can
action means cutting carbon emissions
and wealthy countries stumping up the
cash to help developing countries go
green
we approaching that critical turning
point in less than two months in just
over 40 days
when we must show that we are capable of
learning and maturing and finally taking
responsibility for the destruction we
are inflicting not just upon our planet
but
upon ourselves
it's time for humanity
to grow up
in new york but with a clear eye on
beijing the pm imploring the world's
largest emitter of greenhouse gases to
do more i want to thank very much
president xi of china for what he has
just done to end china's international
financing of coal and i hope china will
now go further and phase out the
domestic use of coal as well wouldn't
that be a great thing
because lining up the targets now ahead
of glasgow in the hope he can convert
them into winds
when kermit the frog
commit the frog
sang
it's not easy being green
do you remember that one
i want you to know that he was wrong
number 10 has always said that this
global gathering was an important stage
in post on the way to cop
and the direction of travel is certainly
going the prime minister's way with
major powers this week move in on
climate change president biden has
pledged to double climate aid funding
while president xi will stop building
coal power stations abroad but it is
prime minister boris johnson who wants
to own the moment on climate change and
he wants to land it on home taft
the prime minister has used his time at
this summit in new york to drum up
support for the climate cause and hype
up his own summit in glasgow but with
the hype comes expectation
beth rigby sky news new york
well the government says deliveries of
carbon dioxide have resumed following a
deal to restart production but the
crisis continues to hit energy firms
with two more companies going bust in
the last 24 hours in a tweet last night
the business secretary quasi quoting
said cf fertilizers have just made their
first delivery of sewer co2 since we
struck a deal to restart production this
will ensure supplies to critical
industries as the t-side plan safely
ramps up to full production uh joined
now by the business minister paul scala
hello to you thank you for joining us on
the programme this morning let's talk
about that first of all should we one
and a half million households apparently
facing a rise in energy bills
um more could be at risk uh is what we
were hearing from quasi-quatting
actually when he was just there the
other day um
we're told that energy prices will
remain exceptionally high during this
winter
will they
well we know that there are um
extraordinary uh set of circumstances
that have built up with um
increased demand in asia with the fire
in ashford
that's caused issues around getting gas
over from france but the majority of our
energy actually is developed
domestically and with norway about 80
between those two
and so we're concentrating on prices
we're making sure that uh we have that
supplier of last resort when the when
companies are leaving the market so that
consumers can be
transferred the energy price cap is is
clearly keeping prices down um
even with those upward pressures for so
many people
and consumers around around around the
country but those are artificially low
prices aren't they and that is reviewed
every six months that price cap that is
undoubtedly going to go up well yeah i
mean there are clearly pressures on that
but what it's still doing what the
energy price cap is still doing it's
still reducing uh prices or the the cap
fought for for for uh millions of people
across the country by around 100 pounds
up to 100 pounds depending on if it's
single fuel or dual foot fuel but yes
off gem that we've we've had lots of
conversations the secretary of state has
with companies themselves with uh off
gem who in reviewing that price cap is
clearly going to uh know that we want to
protect customers not just their supply
but clearly their prices as well what's
your worst case scenario about how much
that price cap will have to go up in the
next six months well as i say that this
is all part of these conversations
because the the thing is we haven't even
thought about it well the thing is the
the
part of the conversation is that off-gen
um well we'll set will set that cap up
because supply
prices are based on a number of factors
uh and clearly as government we need to
uh make sure that we're planning for the
worst case scenario because we want to
make sure what is the worst that we can
we can protect consumers well this is
what we're dealing with with gas
companies with energy companies and off
gem at the moment secretary of state has
been in pretty well back-to-back
commerce conversations with them over
the weekend and throughout this week to
make sure that we can plan for the you
know so what is the worst case scenario
for the price gap well that it goes on
for longer than than a short than a
short spike and this is why what does
that look like like in pounds what does
that look like militarily for people
we're already struggling look i think
that that will develop i can't give you
a figure now because as i say that's
that's really subject the reason i ask
you is because the joseph ranchery
foundation can give us um a figure and
as far as they're concerned they're
looking at their figures and they say 1
750 pounds is how much the cost of
living
crisis is going to increase for families
who can least afford it yeah i think
what you're looking at there we were
talking about this yesterday is this is
uh there's a wider piece of work that
they're doing they're looking at they're
looking at the cost of living in general
what the conversations that i was
talking about
especially at this time of year you have
to accept that oh absolutely no
absolutely so they can come up with a
figure so why can't they no but but as i
say that figure that they've come up
with is is a rounded figure with a
number of factors it's not just talking
about energy and they've made some
assumptions in that what we want to make
sure we we have to we have the very best
evidence from offgem from the energy
companies who are basically the it's the
energy companies that are setting their
um wholesale prices or buying at
wholesale prices so they're the ones
that are going to inform us of how are
we going to move given that you're aware
of of what they have been saying um you
know they're saying that the cost of
living as far as fuel is concerned me is
a can be comparable to what um hard
pushed families spend on clothing and
shoes for their kids yeah look i think i
come back to the point we've we've got
the warm house homes discount uh for for
the lowest paid for people on certain
aspects of pension credit as well who
will automatically get that we have the
winter fuel payment we have the cold
weather payment as well but that energy
price cap as i say is still reducing
prices by um by up to 100 pounds for
dual fuel use the universal credit
payment
what we're going to do about that well i
think and you guys are going to lose
face so you might as well just do it now
look the well again you know the labour
party were pushing this yesterday
without any answers about how it's going
to be paid for because the universal
credit it was there to default um an
emergency situation over the pandemic
situation well the the chancellor would
clearly look at the whole gamut of
public finance so it is something
i'm not saying about the universal
credit because i'm not the chancellor
but he'll look at would you pressure
you'll look at the whole look at it
again
he'll look at the whole aspect of um
public finances in the budget and the
spending review that is coming up
but uh if you if you were to reverse the
universal credit as it is you have to
put income tax up by a pet the
equivalent of putting income tax up by a
penny and so you're saying it's three
depends on fuel get rid of universal
credit or put a penny on it you have to
find six billion pounds don't you think
that most people would accept putting a
penny on income tax so that people can
put food in their kids bellies and shoes
on their feet and heat their homes it's
not one or the other well no what i'm
saying is that you have to find six
billion pounds from somewhere and
actually what you don't want to be doing
for the lowest paid in particular is is
giving with one hand and taking in
increased taxes
impacts on the top five percent most
absolutely doesn't absolutely it's up to
them
in these crisis situations to be helping
people who need the money most well as i
say the budget takes cut it takes takes
into account the public finances at the
moment what we're what we're doing we
are we're increasing the national living
wage we've we've increased um income for
uh by about four thousand people for
four thousand pounds per year for the
lowest paid in our um uh in our society
that's something that fits within my
remit we are increasing wages as well
we've seen wages going up quite rapidly
in some sectors as well
no no we're not
we're seeing it sorry i should have said
we're seeing that going up in quite
rapidly and some sectors that have been
underpaid for some time now and that's
very much to be welcomed we want to also
encourage people and find out what we
can do more to
link the uh record amount of vacancies
to people that are out there universal
credit if i may we understand all of
those and you know we talk about it a
lot in general um yeah and the universal
credit is an easy win for you it would
mean uh
the world to the people who need it most
and if the government says you know what
we've listened to you people who are
voting for us on the red wall and as a
res behind the red wall and as a result
yeah we are going to keep it for another
year at least this is something that
we're looking at for the country as a
whole it's not red wall blue wall or any
sort of political aspect
it's making sure that we we're doing the
right thing for people across the
country especially the lowest paid um
in the country and one of the areas
we're looking at doing at the moment is
reviewing the national minimum wage and
the national living wage that's coming
up for uh consideration uh this year and
we'll take the view from the low pay
commission and what more we can do on
there to me and manifest but you're
sticking with universal credit being
scrapped well as i say it was emergency
measure that that did its job at the
particular time but the chancellor will
look at public finances and look at the
uh the cost of living in his budget in
the spending review coming up it gets
worse um we're hearing from um tesco
they're saying the boss at tesco is
saying that shells could be 10 times
worse they're empty already they could
be 10 times worse before christmas and
that is because we haven't got enough
delivery drivers to deliver the food
around yeah so we're doing uh there is a
global issue actually it's not just a uk
problem there's uh poland is something
like 120 000 htv drivers short germany
45 000 there are issues in canada and
elsewhere as well other countries so we
viewers don't care about that
but i'm just saying yeah and the fact
they can't buy stuff because the shelves
aren't absolutely and i was we were in a
cross-government meeting yesterday
talking about it we're talking about a
regular basis what more we can do and
what can you do
one of the things that we're doing is
there are a number of people there are
hundreds of thousands of people in the
country that have hgv licenses either
full or partial that are not working at
the moment how we can encourage them
back how we can increase the number of
tests to get more people through the
system which has been delayed because of
the pandemic and the changes that the
department of transport have made
will result in about 50 000
new tests over the years but starting
from now so we can start to get them
within the system within the system
there's an easy fix according to um our
man from tesco he says 14 000 hdv
drivers left in the year to june 2020
only 600 have returned what we need is a
temporary amnesty for bringing foreign
workers back which is why i started off
talking about the fact that this is is
that something we're looking at this is
why i started talking about the fact
that this is in in other countries
because actually there's no guarantee if
you've got a shortage in poland if
you've got a shortage in germany and
other countries around the eu my
question is should there be another
there's no guarantee that actually if
you start something you should if you
start opening up a route that actually
people will come back in as as the
person from tescos assumes um but
clearly we'll look at all options in
terms of short term uh issues the longer
term and the medium term uh is something
that the sector will work through but we
will help them do that by making sure
that we can get more htv drivers um in
the pipeline you're saying it is
something that you would look at to have
a temporary amnesty bringing drugs
overseas no i think the the one of the
issues with temporary embassies and and
issuing new visa routes that actually
takes weeks and months to open anyway
so it's not it doesn't quite work that
way so uh by the time you've got you're
the government you're in charge no by
the time you've got systems in the these
do take weeks and months to open anyway
um and so actually
again it's not quite the uh the panacea
uh that you're so you're saying no
it's off the table we don't take
anything off the table but nonetheless
uh what this is why we're looking across
government to make sure that we can and
with the sectors that are most involved
to see what we can come up with both
short term and in the longer term you
here to talk about working from home um
and who it's a good idea for
yeah and it's a
we so we're making uh consulting on
making flexible working the default
option that people can request to work
flexibly that's not just working from
home it's become known as working from
home during the pandemic this hybrid
working but it might be actually
compressing your hours it might be
working core time but having flexible
time start and finish times which is
brilliant for caring it's brilliant for
child care in particular
and other people to give them
flexibility and what that
results in is a happier workforce a more
flexible workforce
and actually tends to lead to more
applicants um coming into um job
vacancies in companies that offer that
kind of flexibility everybody's on board
duncan smith says that civil servants
need to get off their backsides and get
back to work yeah that's about the
return to work that's that simple binary
thing about thinking flexible working is
all about whether you're working from
home permanently because basically
permanently permanent working up from
home is living at work i've done that
myself when i was self-employed
and it's it's a novel idea for a little
while so yes we do you know we want to
encourage people back to the workplace
it's not going to be necessary
the nine to five five days a week in
every workplace but it's up to employers
and employees to have a good discussion
that actually works for both because you
can't have flexible working in every
single workplace but nonetheless as i
say if you get it right you get a better
work better workforce a happier
workforce and ultimately a more
productive workforce just before i let
you go um we've certainly had lots of
doom and gloom during our interview um
today a lot of parents are thinking you
know what i need to take my kids away
for half term if i can possibly afford
it these pesky pcr tests costs a
flipping fortune
are we going to scrap them and if we are
are we going to scrap them in time for a
half turn uh that's absolutely the aim
we've got to get again systems in place
because we want to move to a lateral
flow test
to make it easier
and cheaper for people to be able to
enjoy those holidays at halftime but
hopefully by half time uh that's that's
the the aim is uh later on in october so
uh so we you know we know that the half
term is looming we know that people want
to get away but we also want to
encourage business travel as well
because that's investment in the uk it's
investment in jobs and creating
opportunities for people good to talk to
you thanks for joining us this morning
really appreciate it thank you
still to come on the programme for you
this morning we're going to be
reflecting more on our interview with
the minister we're talking about panic
buying in the supermarkets we'll ask the
boss of iceland
just after eight o'clock this morning
what he thinks is going to happen next
and he keeps us fit during lockdown and
now joe wicks wants to make sure that
preschool kids pick up the fitness habit
as soon as possible
he'll put us through our paces at half
past nine
[Music]
and the charity war child are organizing
an all-star concert for john lennon who
would have been 81 next month it's hoped
that whispering bob paris will give a
shout out for what we can expect at 9
45.
[Music]
let's get reaction now to boris
johnson's speech at the un now from our
u.s correspondent greg milam who is
standing by for us hello to you greg he
says it's not easy being green
channeling his inner kermit
yeah i'm probably the first world leader
ever to mention kermit in the the
general assembly i would imagine some
greek mythology thrown in as well
mention of martinis um but the the
background to all of that was a very
clear warning uh and and one that is
cop 26 that conference he will chair in
six weeks that is a turning point in
humanity as he described it using this
metaphor that our civilization is is
like a teenager trashing the planet uh
we need to grow up and understand
uh what we're doing i guess the judgment
on whether that speech was successful or
not will will come in six weeks time
whether uh that was a whether cop 26 can
be a success because the audience he was
speaking to really in that speech
um was the world leaders who could make
or break cop 26. other people who can
make the decisions and as well as that
speech that very clear warning
there's been work going on by the uk
government in the last few days to get
countries to come up with more ambitious
targets on cutting emissions
coming up with more money for that fund
100 billion dollars 100 billion dollars
a year the fund to to pay poorer
countries to to carry out the changes
they will need to carry out now boris
johnson went to the u.s saying he didn't
feel very optimistic he's become more
optimistic he says that target now is
within touching distance largely because
joe biden has doubled the us commitment
so some room for optimism but i think
even he would say the judgment on that
speech will come in in six weeks in
glasgow
thank you thanks a lot
scientists on the canary islands say a
major volcanic eruption there could
continue until december thousands of
people have been forced to leave their
homes after the island of la palma was
hit by giant lava flows and ash clouds
let's bring in our correspondent ashna
harinaku standing by there for us this
morning a lot of people having to move
their homes ashana good morning
good morning kay a lot of people having
to evacuate their homes it's almost a
miracle really there haven't been any
casualties because of this but the
emergency services have been very quick
to react if i move out of the way you
can take a look at what they have had to
be reacting to we've been told there was
going to be large
seismic activity and that's certainly
the case that spewing volcano is around
four miles away from me but that lava is
shooting up over about a thousand feet
into the night sky you really can't
fathom the speed that that lava is
traveling straight from the center of
the earth those cinders have been
erupting consistently since sunday uh
geologists say these smaller eruptions
have been more frequent over the past
few hours every so often k you'll hear
this raw from the volcano even even
though it is about four miles away from
me as i say it's still you do feel the
effects of it and we've been warned that
there will be lava flows perhaps toxic
gas in the air and volcanic ash but
already the roads are covered in that
volcanic ash that black thick a grainy
substance and it's absolutely everywhere
it's it's on the roads it's on your
clothing and it makes you think how much
of it is in the air and how much of
those particles
are you breathing in
authorities as i mentioned are going to
be waiting for that first sign of light
there you go that large large plume of
lava spewing out there they will be
waiting for that first sign of light
where they'll probably start to assess
the lasting damage from this
no doubt they've got a huge task on
their hands
very dramatic pictures from la palma
this morning thanks so much indeed
thanks for the update
uh other news for you this morning and
uh one and a half million working people
could be forced into hardship this
winter by the disastrous decision to
withdraw the 20 pounds per week
universal credit uplift according to
citizens advice it suggests that
two-thirds of working claimants are
expected to face hardship when the
uplift is abolished at the end of the
month we were talking about that with
the minister weren't very short time ago
boris johnson is under increased
pressure from mps to rethink his
approach to iran in order to release
nazanen zagari ratcliffe the calling for
the pm to label her confinement as
hostage taking and settle a 400 million
pound debt linked to a 1970s arms deal
today marks thousand days since ms
zagari ratcliffe's detention
the jury in the trial of the american
rap star r kelly has started considering
its verdict the 54 year old musician
who's accused of sexually abusing women
as well as young boys and girls chose
not to give evidence
hundreds of personal attack alarms are
being given to women in parts of
southeast london following the murder of
a local teacher sabine nessa was found
dead on saturday near a community center
in greenwich joining us now is aisha
zaid with more information hello to you
i should tell us what happened
well the police have released some new
information on her journey that day it's
believed that spina nessa had left her
home to meet her friend at a nearby bar
it was a journey that should have taken
just over five minutes but she never
made it she was passing through this
park and it's believed that the police
believe that this is where she was
attacked and murdered at around half
past eight on friday evening now a man
in his forties was arrested on suspicion
of murder but he has been released
under an under investigation and a
post-mortem did take place on monday but
that came back inconclusive now sabina's
body was found near a community center
and they believe the attack took place
during a busier time so police are
really urging anyone who may have seen
anything to come forward with
information and in the meantime they've
increased patrols in the area and also
handed out more than 200 personal safety
alarms to women in the area as well the
local community has organized a vigil in
memory of sabina nessa it's taking place
here at 7pm tomorrow and they've asked
anyone who can't attend to light a
candle on their doorstep in memory of
her and amongst the shock and the grief
i think there's a lot of anger as well
because sabine was only walking to meet
a friend she should have been safe
thank you
quick look at what's happening as far as
the weather is concerned for you this
morning southern parts damp for a time
today there'll be some rain in the north
but most places will be fine
now have a look at these pictures there
are cool cats and then there are very
cute cats here we go
this family in australia posted pictures
of a young possum who decided the safest
place to cuddle up was on the back of
their family cat the cat seemed more
than happy to oblige they eventually
persuaded the two animals to separate
and were able to bottle feed the young
possum which is lovely
coming up details of boris johnson's
speech to world leaders at the united
nations overnight as glasgow gears up
for cop 26.
[Music]
government says that income tax will
need to rise if the current uplift in
universal credit is to continue a
temporary 20 pounds increase to the
benefit was put in place during the
lockdown labour says it must be extended
earlier the business minister paul
scully said any further uplift would
mean a rise in income tax
the universal credit it was there to
default um an emergency situation over
the pandemic
situation well the the the chancellor
would clearly look at the whole gamut of
public finance so it is something that
you would like to know i'm not saying
that about the universal credit because
i'm not the chancellor but he'll look at
would you pressure you'll look at the
whole accident again
he'll look at the whole aspect of public
finances in the budget and the spending
review that is coming up
but uh if you if you were to reverse the
universal credit as it is you have to
put income tax up by a pet the
equivalent of putting income tax up by a
penny and
so you're saying it's something depends
on fuel get rid of the universal credit
or put a penny on it you have to find
six billion pounds don't you think that
most people would accept putting a penny
on income tax so that people can put
food in their kids bellies and shoes on
their feet and heat their homes it's not
one or the other well no what i'm saying
is that you you have to find six billion
pounds from somewhere and actually what
you don't want to be doing for the
lowest paid in particular is giving with
one hand and taking in increased taxes
enough
tomorrow's here thoughts tomorrow
well paul scully was saying this spike
in gas prices may not be short-term it
may not be temporary which is what the
prime minister said it was they don't
know for definite because there's so
many moving parts here but they're
planning for it potentially lasting
several months and that's going to mean
a lot of difficulty for a lot of people
we've seen another two energy companies
go bust this morning that means another
800 000 people have got to be shifted to
another supplier they don't need to do
anything that will all just happen
seamlessly but what won't happen
seamlessly is how much money they end up
paying for it because although the
government have introduced a cap if
you're on a very cheap tariff you might
might end up paying hundreds of pounds
more already and so this is going to be
in the words of the business secretary
paul scully's boss yesterday to mps a
very difficult winter for a lot of
people because energy bills are going to
go up food prices are going to go up
because of this carbon dioxide issue and
then you've got a big tax hike in
national insurance and i'd say that
there are quite a lot of jitters among
conservatives about what this is all
going to mean for some of the poorest
households especially when they're
looking at taking away that 20 pound
rise in universal credit and while tory
mps have not really gone on the record
to express their concerns some
conservatives have we've seen that the
mayor of the tease valley the
conservative mayor there saying that
voters trust could be shattered in the
party former leader william hague saying
you need to get a group of ministers
together to try and work out what to do
about this energy crisis imminently
crisis what christ was was sort of some
of the feeling that i was getting from
the interview but he was he did say
if we want to keep the universal credit
then we need to put a penny on income
tax one wonders if that might be a
policy well he was saying that labour
keeps saying don't take away the
universal credit safety net but how
would they pay for it and of course the
backdrop of all of this is the
government don't want to raise income
tax they considered that when they
hiked up national insurance and decided
that that was more palatable for people
so they don't want to raise income tax
no government ever does um so they say
that we have to remove this 20 pounds
from from all these people because it
cost six billion pounds that's a huge
amount of money and we have to start
balancing the books but i think a lot of
um people who have seen the chance of
giving out money throughout the covid
crisis are going to notice in november
when we get the spending review that
he's going to be mostly taking away
okay for now tomorrow tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock this morning of course
looking forward to that already now
start warning from the prime minister
though to the united nations overnight
he told world leaders the upcoming
climate change in glasgow is a turning
point for humanity let's talk about it
in more detail uh the former uk
ambassador to the un sir mark lyle grant
is with us and the former global
engagement director at the white house
brett bruin is also with us hello tebow
thank you for joining us mark to you
first of all what did you make of the
speech
well i think it was a classic boris
johnson speech if you like there was
lots of flourishes quoting uh the greek
poet uh sophocles references to uh
kermit the frog i'm saying that he might
change his name after the greek god of
the north wind to boyas johnson etc but
it was a rallying cry
for
the box 26 in glasgow in six weeks time
he was appealing for more pledges
to cut carbon emissions more money uh to
pay for climate adaptation
it was a single
issue speech at the un and i think he
delivered it pretty powerfully from what
i have seen
um mr bruin um how do you think that the
un general assembly will
feel about being told about kermit the
frog and actually it is easy being green
well look i think world leaders are
accustomed to some of the colorful
language that prime minister johnson has
a habit of using but on the whole i
agree i think the message was a strong
one and this is a unique opportunity
both for the prime minister but also for
the united kingdom to show extraordinary
leadership in a post-brexit era and if
prime minister johnson's call to arms
and and a response a robust response to
the climate crisis is heated it will be
an enormous diplomatic victory for
the british and i think it's something
that uh prime minister johnson can take
credit for and and quite frankly he has
an ally here in the united states with
president biden uh focused very quickly
on the climate crisis and i think uh it
certainly helped the billions of dollars
in commitments that the americans have
added to that hundred billion dollar
goal that the prime minister has
yeah so mark we want a lot of these
world leaders to come to glasgow for cop
26 in november how much of a risk is the
prime minister was the prime minister
taking when he was telling nations to
grow up
well i think it's not a new cry if you
like he uses very colourful languages as
keith was saying um but that's a way of
putting across the message i don't think
people will be uh sort of upset they
know that when they come to cop26 in
glasgow that they're expected to
come with new pledges a lot of countries
have already made new bridges this week
in new york and in weeks before
so it's a question of how much they're
prepared to
offer now i think that there will be
some countries that perhaps will be
represented at slightly lower level uh
than we would like
because they don't feel able to make the
sort of commitments that are expected of
them and they'd rather use the kovid 19
crisis as an excuse if you like not to
turn up in glasgow but expect a huge
number of countries to be there and i
would expect there to be additional
pledges
whether it will fulfill full
expectations of the british government
who knows but i think the americans are
very uh enthusiastic
most of the europeans are behind it it's
a question of whether countries like
china and india who are now among the
biggest
emitters
around the world whether they also will
come to the party
uh mr brown we know that um at the
moment um it's the democrat prime
president and very much on side when it
comes to climate change but you know in
three and a half four years time it may
be a very different situation in the
united states again uh climate change
divides along party lines in the us and
it's very important to the uk that in
order to try and get some of these goals
over the line you need to have the
united states on board it's not a given
though is it going forward
no and in fact there's a nearer term
deadline in just over a year we will
have legislative elections here in the
united states and right now president
biden's party is not faring particularly
well in the polls and we've seen under
president trump how quickly commitments
from cop25 can
evaporate can be
changed radically and so i think there
is legitimate fear as to whether or not
some of these big numbers some of these
big bold ideas that president biden is
putting forward can be delivered upon
and that is going to be a source of
hesitancy for other leaders especially
those in china india and some of the
developing world to say are we going to
want to be on the hook for some of these
big commitments if we can't be sure in a
year or in several years time that the
americans and quite frankly that others
will be there because while prime
minister johnson spoke to world leaders
today ultimately in many of these
countries it's the legislators who have
to cough up the money
um certainly so mark you can't do it
without the president of the united
states we saw them in their meeting um
at the oval office tensions have been a
little bit um high between the two sides
um how would you describe them now they
looked as though they were pretty
relaxed together
yes i think the meeting went very well
from the british government's point of
view
of course there's always going to be uh
tensions versus change of president the
styles of president biden and prime
minister johnson are rather rather
different um but clearly there is a a
lot that they have in common climate is
right at the top of that
list but also we've just seen the
announcement of the
nuclear submarine deal the defense pact
between the united states the united
kingdom and australia that has brought
the countries
together um clearly there were tensions
over afghanistan there's some
difficulties over the trade deal of
course northern ireland but all i think
boys johnson will have been very pleased
not only to be received
in the white house but also the way the
talks went and the way they've been
presented to the media
yeah but miss brown no trade deal um as
yet and not even one on the horizon and
also some tension over what's happening
in northern ireland and basically the
view that the united states should butt
out of the northern ireland protocol
when it comes to a deal with the
european union as a result of brexit
what was your take on that
well i think you're going to find
president biden taking a rather hard
line when it comes to uh ireland
northern ireland this is a country that
he knows very well he has certainly a
lot of personal connections to it and i
think as well the united states has uh
had a fairly consistent line and this i
should also say it is very very unlikely
that a u.s uk trade deal can advance in
the political climate we have here in
the u.s right now and i think that is
while certainly an ambition of the prime
minister one quite frankly where energy
would be better spent elsewhere because
the u.s
is in no mood right now to be looking at
free trade deals and i think uh quite
frankly uh what we are seeing right now
are other areas military security
cooperation where the u.s and the united
kingdom can cooperate but not on free
trade
um gentlemen thank you for um getting up
early and staying up late for us we
appreciate it thank you
thank you
a legal judgment is due this morning
which could have a significant impact on
the uk's abortion laws two down syndrome
campaigners are suing the government for
allowing children with disabilities to
be terminated after 24 weeks of
pregnancy ali fortescue reports
[Music]
since their wedding a year ago james has
been a constant at heidi's side as she
fights a very personal battle i know
it's scary to have um a baby without
syndrome even my mom was scared when she
first had me
heidi's suing the government for
allowing babies with down syndrome to be
aborted after 24 weeks the verdict is
today all i want is for people to accept
us
that's all i want we are amazing just
the way we are
we just see the person behind it as a
chromosome
and that's what i did when i met james
that doesn't define us
she is
an amazing woman
and i'll be holding a hand
and say it's going to be okay
the case has also been bought by moyer
yay fist bump
whose son aiden is two i've got two sons
and i you know i absolutely love them
both and i value them equally and i just
i really feel like the law should as
well it's been really hard work it's
quite emotional and it's been quite
draining at times but
i just so strongly believe that you know
aidan deserves to be treated equally and
seen equally and i would hate for him to
grow up and become aware of this law and
feel hurt by it so yeah i will i will
keep fighting for him
the debate around abortion has long been
fraught the issue here is in a sense
different but ignites the same basic
question when should a mother be able to
choose
conditions which are diagnosed later in
pregnancy can be incredibly complex and
these can be very very
difficult circumstances for women and
their partners to find themselves in and
our current framework
gives women and their partners their
families time
to understand the implications
of that diagnosis to to monitor it to
find out more
and to make a decision in the time frame
that is right for them and not to be
rushed into a decision
around 90 of women whose unborn babies
are diagnosed with down syndrome choose
to have an abortion all eyes today will
be on the high court and a judgment that
could change abortion law as we know it
ali fortescue sky news
if you've been affected by any of the
issues raised in that story you can
contact the samaritans for help and
advice i'll put the number on the screen
for you in the next hour
there it is right now 116 one two three
the labor leader kierst alma has set out
his vision for britain ahead of this
weekend's labour conference uh we'll
talk to the shadow community secretary
steve reed in just a moment
[Music]
i am going part of the amazon biome to
guyana
and i'm crossing the kanuki mountains
now the kanuki mountains are a protected
area in guyana it's very very special
and they're full of a lot of high jungle
mountains and it's a long way i'm sort
of i'm basically tracking the higher the
length the width of guyana um the jungle
expeditions it's so so dense so we can
expect to sometimes only be moving um a
whole day one kilometer maybe in a day
uh it's going to be hard it's going to
be
uncharted unknown the maps about the
only maps i have really are back from
the 70s and they were done by someone in
a plane going past the camera so they're
not not that reliable
but it's just going to be a case of
getting on the ground and seeing what
happens main reason for doing this
expedition is to both celebrate and make
people aware of what can be achieved
when we protect our wild places it's
very very amazing that guyana have been
protected these kaneki mountains and
they're so by full of biodiversity as a
result of it um so that's the first
thing the other thing um i want to do
with this exhibition is to both inspire
and empower hopefully more people to
just get out there and
go go for it go through and achieve
achieve their dreams and see their
potential because that's definitely what
this is about for me i crossed these
mountains this mountain range from south
to north last year a much shorter
journey but it gave me a taste of what's
to come and during that journey
uh it's right in the middle in the
middle of the the worst point where any
danger um
could could show itself came and we got
surrounded by bushmaster snakes and
jaguars and it sounds like something
from a horror film um but i'm very aware
that this this is a big these are big
risks
other risks are
river crossings um deadfall which is
trees falling and of course like
infections and heat exhaustion
but it's all managed risk it's all
things that i've thought about and
trained for and myself and my great team
um are ready for it i'm traveling with
four awesome amerindians all of whom i
know from previous expeditions in the
jungles have handpicked them
they're just their their skills and
their tribal skills they're from
different tribes around the area are
just just going to be so so useful and
the dynamic that we have is very very
special
[Music]
foreign
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
the weather's looking a little mixed for
today we've got early gales over the far
north and rain making its way south over
scotland into northern england it's
cloudy through southernmost counties as
well but the southern ireland parts
wales the midlands east anglia along
with northeastern scotland there'll be
some sunshine and it'll be fairly warm
later on we see rain returning to the
north
but those rather strong breezes that we
have throughout the course of the day
are going to keep air pollution levels
low right across the country
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
labour leader kia stamos set up his
post-pandemic vision for britain ahead
of the party's annual conference this
weekend um fourteen thousand words
apparently zakir talking about the need
for a contribution society involving a
new contract between labour and the
british people the shadow communities
and local government secretary is
joining us now steve tell us mr reed
thanks for joining us i want to talk
about the speech in just a second but
first
pushing the minister in this hour about
universal credit the uplift the 20
pounds it's going to go as we know next
month that's going to make a huge impact
on a lot of families he said the only
option is to put a penny on income tax
well first of all this is not the time
to be cutting universal credit for if
you're earning 18 000 pounds you're
gonna lose a thousand pounds
of your income which is what this this
cut means then you're struggling to put
food on the table you're more likely to
to your family to go into debt they're
really putting the squeeze on working
families today on the point about how do
you pay for it well don't forget this is
this is the government that wasted two
billion pounds on crony contracts to
their wealthy donor friends they wasted
10 billion pounds on a track and trace
system that never work that never that
never worked properly if the government
would stop hemorrhaging public money
on on schemes like that then perhaps
they wouldn't be having to make excuses
today about why they are clobbering
working families again and again and
again it's not just with the universal
credit is it's the national insurance
contributions uh
increase it's the council tax increases
this year and again coming next year
they just turn again and again and again
to global working families working
families simply can't afford it so you
would support a penny increasing income
tax no i would support the government
stopping wasting money and then
supporting those families that need that
additional income to survive so you
think there's money in the system
well we know there's money in the system
because the government's wasting billion
tens of billions of pounds of it well
they would say they weren't wasting that
money
i think two billion pounds on crony
contracts is a waste of money 10 billion
pounds on a track and trace system that
never that never work properly that is
absolute waste and they really need to
stop doing that before they turn to
working families and club club of those
people we we need to tax people fairly
and then spend that money sensibly and
this government just isn't yeah in a
democracy we're only as effective as our
opposition there aren't we and you know
labor have not necessarily got their act
together for several years now some
might say more than a decade your leader
is trying to put that right this weekend
14 000 word missions statement ahead of
party conference this weekend what are
the highlights well he's he's written an
essay setting out his store and i'm sure
i hope he'll be condensing that uh for
his speech that he makes to labour party
conference this coming week but he's
talking about how we recognize the
contribution that people make either as
as workers as volunteers as carers if
you put in in this country then you
should get rewarded for putting in if
you work hard then we need to make work
pay what we're seeing from the current
government is they are clobbering
working people if you're a care worker
for instance
i'm asking about your leader well but
this because this is
this is the point that this is exactly
what he's talking about so if you're a
care worker and you worked really hard
to get the country through the pandemic
right now you're about to see your take
home home pay go down
go down because of
national insurance contribution
increases and no real terms pay increase
if you're working hard as a care worker
you deserve to be rewarded with a pay
increase not a pay cut so what keir will
be doing what labor we will be doing is
making sure that if you work hard we
will make work pay if you're a business
and you're making a contribution to your
community we will try and support your
business by looking at how we can level
the playing field on rates that
currently puts high street retailers at
a disadvantage compared to their online
competitors we have to make the system
fair for working people
all of this is going to get lost in the
weeds isn't it because he wants to
restructure the party the unions don't
like it and some of your colleagues are
describing it as embarrassing uh he's
massively weakened as a result and he'll
be dead on arrival
well what what is what he's doing here
after the pandemic which meant all of us
as mps i mean pretty much everyone was
was unable to get out and do do their
jobs normally kier spent this summer
going up and down the country doing
something that leading politicians don't
normally do he was speaking to voters
that were not supporting our party
so he was listening to people that used
to vote labor that weren't any that are
no longer doing so and he asked them
what the problem was and the key thing
they said is labor's not listening
to us we need to focus on their concerns
the essay he's written and the speech he
will give will start to be addressing
those concerns but the rule changes in
the party are also to look structurally
at what is it that's stopping us getting
out
and listening to voters more one of the
problems is for instance when we were
ahead of the last general election while
opponents our opponents spent the summer
knocking on doors talking to voters we
had to spend that summer knocking on
doors talking to labour party members no
i love talking to labour party members
they they're knocking on doors in day in
day out for our party but they expect us
to win a general election and that means
talking to voters so changing the rules
so that we can get out and talk to the
voters
means that we've got a better chance of
winning that next election and then
doing what we need to do to protect
working people okay so will you be able
to change the rules a party conference
or will it be months of wrangling well
we're a democratic uh party we'll have
to see how it pans out overly over the
next few days well there's a
conversation there's a conversation
going on like here's kiss put forward
some proposals he's never said it's
being put forward on a take it or leave
it basis are you hopeful he'll be able
to everybody everybody in the labour
party you know the trade unions our
affiliated organizations our memberships
our mps we all want labour to win so if
the rules are getting in the way well
let's look at how we can adjust those
rules so they work better to deliver the
thing that we all want which is a labor
government to replace these
conservatives so that we can protect the
working people that boris johnson keeps
coming back and clobbering again and
again and again do you think my question
is do you be able to get those real
changes through i don't know it's a
democratic system i hope so okay that's
as good as i can you're bringing it up
if you don't think you're going to be
able to get the true mystic meg and i
can't tell you exactly what's going to
happen but i really hope we can because
if we put our party in a better position
to win the next election then we can do
our best for those people that
desperately need a labour government
right now good to talk to you thanks
very much for joining us on the program
this morning thank you still to come uh
in the next hour for you a warning from
the government as you're just discussing
there with labour that your income tax
will have to rise if the temporary
uplift in universal credit is to
continue have you got a thought on that
would you be happy to pay a penny more
on your income tax in order for families
to be able to not only heat their homes
but also put food in their kids bellies
and shoes on their feet or is that just
too simple stay tuned
[Music]